Florida lawmakers are taking a close
look at the state's airboat industry
following the death of a college
graduate they are considering
legislation to tighten regulations for
the popular tourist industry 22 year old
Ellie Goldenberg died in an airborne
airboat crash last year along maker
backing the Florida House bill says
there have been seven airboat related
deaths and a hundred and two serious
injuries in the last three years Manuel
Bojorquez is on an airborne airboat near
Orlando Florida of how this addresses
safety concerns Manuel good morning
good morning we're told the engine you
see here is similar to that of a racecar
and can get the boat going to up to
about 40 miles per hour the captains at
this business are certified by the Coast
Guard but some airboat drivers aren't
required to have any type of training or
certification we got a first-hand look
at the undeniable draw of air boating
just outside Orlando it's clear to see
why people love coming out here yeah
this is what it's all about
but in South Florida the death of 22
year old honor student le Goldenberg is
prompting Florida state lawmakers to
take a closer look at the largely
unregulated airboat industry last May
David and Renee golden Berg's daughter
Ellie an aspiring Broadway singer
graduated from the University of Miami
we decided to go out on a celebratory
airboat tour in the Everglades a day
after graduation the Goldenberg signed
up for an airboat tour that turned
tragic a short while into the tour the
driver sped up to over take another
airboat that was either stock or had
stopped and he flipped our airboat the
couple's daughter Dana was thrown under
the boat and burned she survived but
Ellie became trapped facedown and
drowned the greatest part of the boat
that covers the engine fell on top of
her and pinned her down so I watched her
take her last breath it happened so fast
it was just unbelievable I think we
would never imagined to be in that
position according to the company that
gave the tour the airboat captain had
given over 10,000 rides and with CPR
trained
CPR training along with taking a safety
course approved by the state are two
provisions of a new safety bill Florida
state representative Joe Abruzzo is
co-sponsoring we're talking about being
out in the middle of the Everglades
you're far away from any type of first
responders to get there immediately and
you need somebody trained to treat these
injuries
Sam Hawk Cole owns wild Florida you have
some unique challenges with an airboat
there are no breaks there's no reverse
the business gives airboat rides to 350
people a day it's not often that you
hear business owners say yes we actually
want more regulations people don't hear
a specific airboat company got in an
accident they just hear airboats and so
it really puts kind of a black cloud
over people's desire to come out david
Goldenberg doesn't want the new
legislation named Ellie's law to define
his daughter's legacy
it's unfortunate by-product that we are
putting in place to try and make sure
that no other family has to lose a loved
one if you've ever heard her sing so
that smile
that's her legacy the proposed law would
impact commercial air boat captains and
not those who take these out
recreationally the company involved in
the Goldenberg death told CBS News it
supports the bill which is still making
its way through the Florida Legislature
Gail hmm Thank You Manuel a cautionary
tale indeed it's Oh your heart breaks
for the golden bird family because you
go on vacation you think you're doing
something fun and in a split second your
life is forever changed unthe at before
it is a beautiful tour it is see the
Everglades because we were like do not
go fast yeah I was like Nana on the boat
very important information